what we're going to do in this video is
think about how the core beliefs of u.s
citizens impacts their views on the role
of
government and what i'm going to do is
talk about a few core beliefs that are
often associated with the united states
but take it with a grain of salt it's
obviously a very large and a very
diverse country where people have many
many many beliefs
now one thing that often gets associated
with the united states is this idea of
self-reliance
or sometimes would be called
individualism or these are related ideas
individualism
and this is the idea that hey look an
individual if people don't get in their
way can take care of themselves that the
goals of that individual should
sometimes or often trump those of the
collective of or say the government and
so you can imagine someone who has a
strong core belief in self-reliance or
individualism they would want a limited
government they would say hey government
just get out of my way and i can take
care of myself
now a related idea to that but this
would be going into the
corporate realm or the entrepreneurial
realm is the idea of free enterprise
free enterprise
and this is the idea that hey we can
generate wealth we can create things we
can innovate once again if enterprise if
entrepreneurial activity is left to its
own devices now once again this core
belief in free enterprise would probably
favor a limited government hey
government just get out of my way the
more that you get involved that just
slows things down that just is a wet
blanket on the creativity and on the
wealth creation that we could do left to
our own devices
now another idea
is that of equality of opportunity often
associated with the united states
equality of
opportunity and this goes to the roots
of the united states where we don't have
a formal nobility obviously we don't
have things like kings that the country
started off obviously there's some major
exceptions around things like slavery
but the the country took pride in ideas
of equality of opportunity and to some
degree they feed into these first two
bullet points that if there truly is
equality of opportunity it kind of backs
up the idea that hey let's just let
people take care of themselves now on
the other hand someone who really cares
about equality of opportunity might say
well hold on a second not everyone is
born into the same circumstance and
because of that if you truly care about
equality of opportunity there might be a
role for the government to play in
helping to level that playing field a
bit so these folks might not want as
limited of a government as some of the
folks who are strongly in the camp of
self-reliance or individualism
now the fourth core belief i'll talk
about and that is the rule of law rule
of law now any country in order to
function needs a rule of law but one
thing that the united states takes pride
in itself and i think united states
citizens take pride itself is that hey
look if there's going to be a contract
between individuals people will uphold
that contract that because of a solid
rule of law it's less likely that people
will get away with crimes and there are
examples that you could look around the
world where people might have less faith
in the rule of law yeah people are
getting away with stuff or if i get into
an agreement with someone there's no way
that i can really enforce that agreement
and so the rule of law this would argue
for some role of government but it
depends how focused or how limited of a
rule of law people's core beliefs are
and to make these core beliefs and their
impact on government a little bit more
tangible i have some quotes from some
notable americans now several of these
are presidents but their views are
really indicative of broader views in
the american population
so this first one comes from president
ronald reagan
and he said
government's first duty is to protect
the people
not run their lives so which core
beliefs do you think ronald reagan is
representing here
well when i look at this it seems like
he doesn't want the government to really
mess with people's lives he's really
talking about self-reliance
individualism free enterprise and he is
making some reference that look there is
a duty to protect the people so he's
saying there is you do need the
government to enforce the rule of law
but he seems to favor a limited
government and he indeed did favor a
limited government that does not get in
the way of say free enterprise or
people's ability to be self-reliant
now some would argue on the other end of
the spectrum here is a quote from
franklin roosevelt in which he said
not only our future economic soundness
but the very soundness of our democratic
institutions depends on the
determination of our government to give
employment to idle men
so fdr here is talking about a very
active government not a the type of
limited government that ronald reagan
seems to allude to here he's saying that
it's the job of the government and
remember the context years fdr was
president during the great depression
and the beginning of world war ii
and during the great depression you had
massive unemployment and he's saying
look the not only the future of our
economic soundness but the very
soundness of our democratic institutions
depends on the determination of the
government to give employment to these
men now his argument might have been
look if we don't give employment then
you could have a revolution on your
hands people are going to lose faith in
in this idea of the united states
they're going to lose faith in the
government now on the other hand some
people might say the whole reason why we
were in that mess is that the government
was intervening too much and the more
that the government intervenes it
actually might not allow free enterprise
to naturally solve the economic
situation that we were in at the time
but once again franklin roosevelt seemed
to be a little bit less on self-reliance
because he said look these people aren't
going to find jobs on their own the
government needs to get them jobs now
here's another viewpoint this is from
president barack obama
and here president obama says the
internet didn't get invented on its own
government research created the internet
so that all the companies could make
money off the internet the point is is
that when we succeed we succeed because
of our individual initiative but also
because we do things together so this is
an interesting argument he's when he's
saying this he's clearly making
reference to these ideas of
individualism and free enterprise that
are strong core beliefs in the united
states this individualism is we succeed
because of our individual initiative and
free enterprise these companies that are
making money off the internet but his
point is that these things didn't happen
on their own that at least in this case
the internet was started as a government
project you had darpanet and arpanet
which eventually evolved into the
internet so that free enterprise could
take over and you know frankly allow you
to watch this video he's saying that the
government actually does have a role
here and because of that role that the
government has played it has actually
allowed things like self-reliance
individualism and free enterprise to
flourish even more
and last but not least i'll give you a
quote from famous conservative economist
milton friedman he used to be a
professor at the university of chicago
and he said
government has three primary functions
it should provide for military defense
of the nation it should enforce
contracts between individuals it should
protect citizens from crimes against
themselves or their property and so
milton friedman here is clearly
advocating for a limited government in
terms of his core beliefs
clearly from the statement he says look
a rule of law is necessary you have to
have your
contracts between citizens you need to
protect citizens from crimes against
themselves or their property if you read
more milton friedman quotes and i
encourage you to regardless of where you
are on the philosophical spectrum
they're all quite interesting he has a
strong underlying core belief in
self-reliance individualism and free
enterprise but i'll leave you there
think about it on your own how does the
core belief of a united states citizen
including yourself how does that impact
your view of the role of government